une fermeture qui a pris du temps évoqué
au fil des can am est désormais bel et
bien décidé par emmanuel macron l'école
nationale d'administration créée en 1945
par le général de gaulle pour
centraliser la formation des hauts
fonctionnaires est critiqué pour ses
dérives élitiste sera remplacé par un
institut qualifié de plus démocratique
l'institut supérieur de préparation aux
grandes écoles formera tous les élèves
administrateurs de l'état et intégrera
un tronc commun attrait école de service
public
une révolution profonde en terme de
recrutement vous savez la volonté de
briser les corporatismes et d'avoir une
haute fonction publique plus efficace
plus attractive plus souple plus à
l'image de la société a été exprimée par
le président de la république préfets
ambassadeurs recteurs ou encore
directeurs des administrations ce nouvel
institut localiser toujours à strasbourg
aura pour objectif d'être plus adaptées
aux problématiques contemporaines et à
la diversité française finit l'accès
direct aux grands corps comme
l'inspection des finances le conseil
d'état et la cour des comptes
les nouveaux lauréats démarreront leur
carrière comme administrateur de l'état
avec plusieurs missions de terrain avant
de connaître leur affectation elle la
fermeture de l'ena évoqué par emmanuel
macron il y a deux ans en pleine crise
des gilet jaune et réaffirmé en février
dernier le président français prône l
égalité des chances avec pour slogan
n'ayez pas peur vous avez votre place
beaucoup de présidents de la république
ont voulu transformer l'ena beaucoup
sont un peu cassé les dents sur la
réforme de l'ena
ce qui montre qu'il ya des
conservatismes aussi et bien maintenant
il faut rechercher une plus grande
agilité une plus grande réactivité mais
aussi des carrières plus proche du
terrain
c'est un des objectifs de cette réforme
aujourd'hui à un an de l'élection
présidentielle l'opposition se montre
critique envers le président entre
populisme et coup politique
le problème ce n'est pas les n'a ni les
fonctionnaires
le problème c'est le politique qui ne
dirige plus qu'ils ne réforment plus la
décision d' emmanuel macron de supprimer
l'ena est une lâcheté pour mieux masquer
l'absence d'une réforme de l'état le
pays et représentant de l'eau les gars
yémen
elle macron supprime l'ena pour faire un
coup de com par quoi va-t-il la
remplacer une business school de
politiques publiques
le vrai enjeu c'est la démission du
politique face à la technocratie de
bruxelles et au milieu des affaires ena
ou pas et n'a on parlera sérieusement de
l'état en france
quand il sera redevenu un état c'est à
dire quand on gérera notre monnaie nos
frontières notre commerce nos lois quand
la france sera un pays souverain
car pour le moment tous ces débats sont
du bavardage et jean luc mélenchon
évoque de son côté une diversion suprême
en pleine crise sanitaire et polémiques
et une grande partie de cette réforme de
la haute fonction publique doit être
adopté avant le 7 juin sous ordonnance
emmanuel macron qui a d'ailleurs appelé
à un débat démocratique autour de la
rémunération des hauts fonctionnaires
très inférieure à celle des dirigeants
d'entreprise